good afternoon can everyone hear me fine
welcome to arrow scene and the future in
a fossil free world I'm thrilled to be
moderating and making introductions
guiding the conversation this evening
with an extraordinary group of people
and we are welcoming Thomas Edison
though here at MIT the event is
co-sponsored by the MIT Center for art
science and technology and the MIT
Department of Architecture my name is
John Fernandez I'm a professor in the
Department of architecture in the
building technology program and I'm the
director of the Environmental Solutions
initiative mi t--'s effort institute
wide effort to mobilize the capacity of
our researchers our students our
community to offer solutions on climate
change and other environmental
challenges that we face in this century
the it's a wonderful group it's a highly
distinguished group there's a lot of
it's a very multidisciplinary group and
because they are so distinguished I have
long introductions for you so they're
bare with me
it's worth going through them and I will
go through them in detail because I do
think that this is the best way to set
up what has really motivated this event
and that is to bring disciplines
together that are quite disparate and
and often distant from one another on
our greatest societal challenges is one
of the pathways towards solving those
challenges really addressing those
challenges so beginning with tomás
Saraceno right here
Tomas his work could be seen as ongoing
research informed by worlds of art
architecture Natural Sciences
astrophysics and engineering and
material science and other things
actually his floating sculptures and
interactive installations propose and
explore new sustainable ways of
inhabiting and sensing the environment
Eero seen an open-source community
project for artistic
in scientific exploration initiated from
satis Anna's vision becomes buoyant only
by the heart but only by the heat of the
Sun an infrared radiation from the
surface of the earth in 2015 satis Anna
achieved the world record for the first
and longest certified fully solar manned
flight during the past decade he has
initiated initiated collaborations with
renowned scientific institutions
including MIT the Max Planck Institute
the Nanyang technology technological
University of Singapore and the Natural
History Museum in London he was the
first person to scan reconstruct and
reimagine spiders woven spatial habitats
and possesses the only three-dimensional
spider web collection in existence I
gather you were chasing spiders this
afternoon sedessa no lectures in
institutions worldwide and directed the
Institute of architecture related art at
Braunschweig University of Technology in
Germany and has held residences at Santa
nazuna
de toutes speciale MIT Center for art
science and technology and the Atelier
Calder among others I'm going to go
through all the introductions okay and
and then the the sequence will be that
they will be giving 10 minute 10 minute
presentations and then we'll have a
panel discussion joining us is Lola Vika
alladhi and the really the host for
Tomas today is a senior lecturer in the
MIT Department of Earth atmospheric and
Planetary Sciences she earned a PhD in
atmospheric sciences at Imperial College
London in 1982 she teaches large-scale
dynamics and synoptic meteorology in mi
t--'s undergraduate and graduate
programs she's responsible for the
synoptic laboratory alladia search
interests are in synoptic meteorology
severe weather and Atmospheric blocking
she's also involved in developing
innovative teaching methods that can
block combined fluid laboratories with
synoptic data and outreach to the public
and schools
therefore the connection to Aero seen
recently she has collaborated with MIT
visiting artists Thomas Edison on the
era scene project imagining how solar
infrared balloons can be used to teach
about earth climate and sample
atmospheric
Institue ins we also have thrilled to
have been welcomed dance it so for also
from the MIT Department of Earth
atmospheric and Planetary Sciences he's
professor of atmospheric chemistry since
2011 and his research focuses on the
role that particulate matter plays in
atmospheric chemistry visibility and
cloud formations visiting in his lab is
quite an experience he creates very
small atmospheres and is in his machines
actually examples include understanding
how aerosols nucleate water and ice
clouds improving the quantification
of meteor meteor re-take ablation
products and determining the abundance
of aircraft and rot rocket exhaust since
those undergraduate work was an
aerospace engineering and he spent two
years at the Jet Propulsion Laboratory
performing spacecraft navigation before
starting his graduate work
Chitra received an MS and PhD in
geophysical sciences from the University
of Chicago for for work with professor
John Abbott his postdoctoral fellowship
was within dr. daniel murphy at NOAA
Irana me laboratory and he spent three
years at the Swiss Federal Institute of
Technology working with Professor Eric
Roman before coming to MIT tsatsa was a
research scientist at the Pacific
Northwest National Laboratory where he
directed their atmospheric measurement
laboratory and finally Bob Jaffe is the
Jane and Otto Morningstar professor of
physics at MIT a theoretical physicist
his research focuses on the physics of
elementary particles in quantum field
theory especially the dynamics of cork
confinement and the standard model he
has served as an advisor to several
national laboratories and universities
including as chair of the science and
engineering steering committee of the
brookhaven national laboratory at MIT
Jaffe has served as chair of the faculty
and director of the Centre for
Theoretical Physics and has received
many awards for teaching and course
development from 2008 to 2016 Jaffe was
the member of the was a member of the
American Physical Society panel on
public affairs which he chaired in 2015
in 2011 Jaffe led
joint American Physical Society panel on
public affairs and mrs study on energy
critical elements security materials for
emerging technologies and together with
Professor Washington Taylor Jaffe
developed and taught a new course on the
physics of energy which was adopted as a
foundational requirement for MIT energy
minor degree the textbook which we all
waited with bated breath to come out and
has been out since March correct is an
outgrowth of the course the physics of
energy and was published this past March
Jaffe is a fellow of the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences the
American Association for the Advancement
of science and the American Physical
Society so welcome to all I'd like to
have Tomas come up and give us your
presentation thank you
mm yeah hello hello yes hello can you
hear me yes wonderful maybe we can turn
a little bit down the light if it's
possible sorry
a video mmm a little bit 50% thank you
no I'm a visual artist sometimes and and
I love that we try to focus on the
images and the other things that I
promise today that I will really try to
keep it with a 10 minutes and maybe you
kind of help me to the 900 and what
should I say that is a horror and I'm
very very happy to be back at my team
and I feel a little bit being at home
sometimes and they say oh when we come
today that I'm again with a good friends
and doesn't mean I'm very very happy to
be here back and and their thing is like
a little bit like what is happening with
the project is somehow it became so much
weather-dependent doesn't mean I think
so we have been so much talking during
the last days that it's cloudy and
hopefully the Sun will come out to be
able to perform some activities down the
road is engagement
psychologically there are some how I
became much more aware of the weather
down the road now I have a presentation
and we try to really to try to compress
it and go as fast as possible and try to
match it in there 10 minutes does it
mean there we go
this one my favorite place on earth the
salar de uyuni in bolivia when it
covered with a thin layer of water the
clouds reflect and there are days once
feels as it were floating in the clouds
but there are days when the horizon
disappear and there is never either
above nor below you feel mercy something
bigger where that's not disguise where
where does the sky ends in the earth
beginning and it was there that one
night in the middle of a dream I woke up
and I saw that the stars also reflected
on the water
and it was not a dream it was like I
will could walk among the star every
step it took the star reverberate under
my feet it was like feeling floating in
the universe among the clouds of
galaxies I do not know about you but I
always dream about floating among the
clouds and today maybe we can imagine
this together we can live in an
ecosystem floating among the clouds
cloud cities is a long-term project of
mine that where we speculate and venture
of new airborne dwellings no maddox and
transnational they belong to everybody
it does not not depend on any type of
sovereignty in the way that we hope that
Cloud City could anticipate a borderless
open-source free flying utopia existing
existence and as we said before imagine
is the force that we can lead us to
create new places this is an
installation I did on a roof for the
Metropolitan Museum New York in which we
speculate out this transnational space
could be the image of the earth from
pace from space does not show any border
has any special constraint but on it we
build vertical and horizontal boundaries
this image for example show the air
space is divided into section allowing
different typology of fossil fuel craft
aircraft to each one of them and project
national boundaries into the atmosphere
equals a nightmare every time one we
launch one of these sculptures to cross
the airspace this is why I think so we
could not let it fly from here because
there are too many airports nearby
well Enterprise to colonize other
planets are put in place with very same
interface between us and the Sun and the
atmosphere continue to be compromised
carbon emission fill the air invisible
radio waves develop in a demonic
algorithm of dominance practice map
particular matter float inside our lungs
air has become law rised by drone
satellites and military devices and
strictly regulated by national policies
and land how could be how could be
breathing fill in a post fossil fuel
economy
it is urgent to rethink how we can
coexist with the planet and its
resources and what a static rafi of the
future will look like yet what weed flow
today in the water are not only cloud of
galaxies but also cloud of plastics
these are the traces that we are living
on the planet are the marks of the era
in which we the behavior of some people
is living a global impact on the rest or
ecosystem this time had been named
Anthropocene all all of these have
transformed the way of human sense of
react to the air to achieve long-lasting
change people must relearn the
relationship with the elements and
understand how can we live in tandem
with them rather than to control it to
be aware of the air is to the sense it
to one's environment to be aware of the
element which you stain you transmit
carry if you leave a room the kate of
building climbing a mountain float in
the sea are you still contained within
the air the air sense the environment
but it is also any kind of social
structure thing so we kind of ran late
we got 5 minutes and you mean we kind of
come up kind of a little bit to
understand the beginning of the project
we start to collect a lot of plastic bag
we wash them we take care we cut them we
paste them and we began to drown them
creating gigantic canvases we create a
collection of drawing personal stories
and friendships and when the campus
unites for bands a space is formed once
full is one once full of air it's not a
matter of time until the air inside the
sculpture and the Sun coming up from the
horizon that's cultural rise up into the
air as simple as it looks and does it
mean the way how it float is really
really simple as such that it's so
simple that is also that no plant or
animal who float in the same way as how
this sculpture float there's no plant or
animal in the entire planet who flow by
this differential of temperature
there are many pollen bacterias and
who are raised in the Thermomix and my
get up into the air but not by this
differential temperature is the same it
accumulates now when you float in the
water you put your length full of air
and then somehow you float in the water
in the same way these sculptures get up
into the air and isn't mean this way we
don't use fossil fuel like normal value
one might have a burner or a candle and
then many other people are also heating
the air through solar panel batteries
and then using also many times helium
which is a byproduct of many times of
fossil fuel instructions and hydrogen is
quite complicated also to to make it
this amine following on that we thought
oh maybe we could think about a new hip
book who might get us more proactive and
not extend and think about different
metabolic regime of our human also have
inhabited the earth and it might be the
fourth metabolic regime to certain
extent and this is why this is the
backpack and inside the backpack there
is this culture and this is the one that
we will try to tomorrow on Friday and on
Saturday to get up into the air they
have different devices which I think so
is what with loro and many communities
around the world we are trying to
optimize and who thinks of how we could
sense their differently in this case
there's a motion tracker and then make
these beautiful drawings there are
different community around the world
which are clearly really hacking
transforming and changing this mean I'm
very happy to hear what will be the
devices we will lift up tomorrow here
there are kind of a performance we are
trying to put up together there is
quacking which is coming from Argentina
also and he's working with a community
you want to tell us two words only yes
my pleasure I'm just gonna show you a
brief images of how we're building a
community around the Ariston project in
Argentina this is how we brainstorm we
get together for an asado and we discuss
or barbecue we discuss some ideas with
Tomas and a group of people in Buenos
Aires back in December
I like to just tell you about this woman
who's called Deborah and wrote a book
called flammable about this community
living near petrochemical plant and
basically it's very near the center of
the city they have huge health problems
and so we have partnered with people to
create quality an air quality monitor
and we have been talking with MIT people
today so to see how we can improve this
and basically get the air quality
monitor air Verne and also we're
thinking about ideas of having an aerial
mesh network that is 100% solar-powered
the first ever solar-powered aerial mesh
network and over to Thomas yes zero I
can stop whatever you want I don't have
any pressure but yeah there is a lot of
life up into the air well some of his
sculptures yes have been free flying we
launched have something from Berlin most
of the time we get a lot of problem
we're getting the air regulation being
able to tune with these type of
sculpture we will be next week talking
with a European Minister of
Transportation of trying to change the
right of paths for this type of vehicles
does it mean also we are trying to set
up a different legal framework in
relation with insurance and translation
of papers and and we will try to lift up
also the Minister up into the air
doesn't mean some of the things that we
have been doing to it Laura and that is
she will show the floating predictor and
Glenn and Bill and apes is this idea of
really being able to circumnavigate the
earth also during the night and picking
up the infrared radiation from the earth
something which Christ the French Space
Agency have been doing during the 70s
and somehow the program have been it
will be forgotten
and is it mean yeah okay these are some
of these sculptures we present you cop21
conference in Paris at the Grand Palais
which are the ones that's more or less
will be able to fly also during the
night and right wind at least a lot of
these you will talk about that
skip that slides but what we want this
kind of artistic also it's like all
these drawing feather flight free fly or
imaginary flights and somehow this
collection somehow it will became kind
of a signature store maybe Independence
Day of fossil fuel that we are all
trying to sign we are collecting all
these drawings and we are lifting up
different people up into the air also
and this was a performance which was
done in the white sand in New Mexico
where was kind of the beginning of
Anthropocene with the first atomic stop
okay I stopped I promised a minute thank
you
[Applause]
hi it's a great pleasure to be here and
also a big thanks to me to follow the
math step but what I'm going to do is
talk a bit about the science we did in
the Racine project and the work I'm
going to describe is not only my work is
in collaboration very close
collaboration with Professor Green
Farrell and Bill McKenna brought cnips
and the collaboration which was massive
started quite a few years ago and this
mainly focusing on next on describing
some work on the exploring the use of
solar balloon as a platform for absorb
in the atmosphere - manses already
mentioned that in his talk on the side
here sorry I want to go back east but
you just seen the movie one of these
solar balloon and this is the one we try
to fly again this weekend and I'll
describe a little bit more what we want
to do next so this the stages of our
collaboration I decided split it in
three some historical some study of
historical balloon from the French Space
Agency that we presented up in Paris at
cop21 then some work on virtual balloon
flights with the float predictor that
Tomas just mentioned and then some
tether balloon the Explorer that we want
to use for chemical sampling of the
atmosphere and particles in on campus so
this is the French attempt or attempt
very successful use of solar balloon
they actually called [ __ ] fear infra
Roush their solar and infrared and this
is one of the balloon is a huge one is
intended to reach the stratosphere and
is filled with just there and it's got a
particular configuration if you look in
here at the diagram the top you can see
the top is a polyester color I will
cover with aluminum so it can if the Sun
sunshine on it
the luminol gets very hot it's the hair
inside the balloon and it gets expanded
I had expanded becomes buoyant but there
is a particular feature that I want to
point out on the bottom of the is
transparent if you notice here is
actually transparent and it's
deliberately done because he wants to
Ernest also the infrared radiation from
Hertz so you know that the earth his
body would emit in all direction for
ahead and so some of this infrared
radiation will be captured by the
balloon so imagine the Sun Goes Down
there inside gets colder but enough is
red radiation is captured to keep it
buoyant and this is the name longer
fearing Fred oh gosh and here is data
that we acquired through their totem a
spring from his internship at Ness real
data of one of this flight launched at
in Brazil in February 2004 you reach 25
kilometer I in the stratosphere and he
didn't get colder because the night came
came down then up again and then down
again the following line and then it
adjusted to a kind of fluctuating
day and night undulation
from between 25 and 20 kilometers and
the flow like that for 12 days this is a
12 days track very smoothly steady on on
wind from east-west and just to describe
the structure of the wind in the
atmosphere we made a section here and in
blue and cyan we have wind blowing from
the west and in the pink and gold we
have wind blowing from the east so
clearly that at this level in the
stratosphere at this particular latitude
you have a very strong flow from the
east and this is what was used to to
travel to make the balloon travel the
idea the balloon was intended to measure
chemicals ozone methane water vapor all
chemical very sensitive to the climate
of the averts and I just want to
and the many flights were done by the
kinase and there's a record of 72 days
so they kept it up for 72 days so that I
could in 2001 and and they was very
successful as in the tropics they had
more problem in the Arctic because you
can imagine that if you have clouds and
low level then they stopped the infrared
radiation and the balloon will come up
so very successful for the tropical
exploration of the stratosphere but not
so much for the extra tropic in the
Arctic
so Saracino after is the internship and
they came to visit us here at MIT really
wanted to really propose this technology
and we made a study of the of the data
and we presented a work a cop21 and I
think this was the beginning of our
collaboration and I actually was hooked
on this data was amazing for me to
discover that you could keep a balloon
of that dimension for so long flying in
the stratosphere now the second part of
our collaboration isn't very well
instead involving and say well my this
areas in sculpture go I want to mention
here demands doesn't call them balloon
anymore because they are beautiful they
are really much better than the other
one I've just shown you these are the
sculptures presented at cop21 in Paris
and so the question that he had is say
where this sculpture could go can I go
up on one a label come down on the other
take the westerly the easterly go around
in a circle so we developed that
together with professor Glenn Ferran and
build an interactive interface to be
able to check where this virtual balloon
could go so I want to give you a quick
demonstration of this and I'm going out
now I'm going to be kind of adventurous
going out on the web and this is
something that is going to be available
for you to explore after the talk and
and also tomorrow in Lobby 10 and it's
plotted here is interactive interface we
can actually move the sphere
and check this is the wind a
10-kilometer is the wind speed coded in
color from weak to strong is the pink is
very strong and you see the traditional
the common feature of jet in the
atmosphere we all familiar with the jet
stream covering the weather system and
this is actually driven by today's data
this is the forecast data that is used
for the ten-day forecast is actually 16
day forecast from the National Weather
Service so I want to give you just a
small kind of example of what I could do
so imagine us saying I start from Boston
and I am now a 10 kilometer high with
this wind where should I go
so I click here and immediately you have
an interactive trajectories computing
following the flow so this you following
me so the flow is evolving in you moving
with the flow like the balloon of the
mass and you can see that rich
Europe and the Mediterranean is got
diverted quite a bit and it's come back
in the jet but it's not managed to go
around the globe now the wind is very
different a different level if you
scroll through you can see the
difference much weaker at the surface
stronger at the jet level then strong
again but weaker I wrap and I'm choosing
the 25 kilometer because it's where the
mere the mungo fearing for usually used
to fly and now I'm trying to do the same
experiment that they were used to do
with this wind I'm putting a balloon
here and see where he will go and you
can see they were pretty clever the
French they knew there was this band of
easterly flow and they could follow and
I find show you the word the change of
this trajectory thinking we're going to
go around all the globe in approximately
15 days and they the exploring this has
been that this interface has been good
not only for exploring the wind in the
atmosphere but also teaching the main
feature of the atmosphere in my classes
so it's been a great development from
the point of view of our teaching so I'm
going to go back to the presentation and
show you the
stage which is making news instead are
not free flight but it had a balloon you
can imagine that whether free flight you
have to go through permission from the
FAA is not easy and so we thought why
not try to experiment with a smaller
balloon which are Tedder and try to use
them to sample pollution in the lower
troposphere so this is our first attempt
last summer in July when it was very hot
he went up he got buoyant very easily he
got up he got up nearly at the top of
the green building we have to keep it
down because we could not raise it
higher than the green building and then
we tried we did another experiment in
October and tomorrow and next Saturday
will be our third attempt with different
sensor so the science application is
monitoring atmospheric chemical and
particles in the lower troposphere the
collaboration this time is with
Professor Jesse Crowell when the
students which is an expert in
monitoring but is mainly does it at the
ground is not done really vertical
profile so it's very excited to try to
test the vertical profile of this
pollutant which variable are we
interested in monitor what can we
measure and where here we try to
summarize a little bit that they are
different variable because there are
different structure if you look at the
know X which is a big pollutant is
really confined in the lower troposphere
this is also zone product product of
interaction with you know X which is
also very local in the lower carbon
monoxide is also local down in the in
the troposphere and then a lot of
different particle that have could be
residual from combustion they could be
dust and they spread as high as 10
kilometer or even more and then we'll
talk about those with an expert
ozone tend to be concentrated I rap and
this is where those stratospheric flight
were trying to measure the maximum of
zone production is actually around 20
kilometer and the usual the
thermodynamic variable that
I'm interested in as a meteorologist
temperature humidity will also be a
target how can we measure them so we
want to create a kind of community of
user all over the world to measure this
quantity and with balloons but what type
we can use the MIR balloon I wrap a
suggestion to you imagine it over in up
and down for 72 days or even longer if
you can and take a measurement of ozone
methane very important for the
greenhouse effect and lower here much
easier and we can even do it on campus
with students and measure the pollution
with this tedder balloon so we're going
to try to do this tomorrow if the Sun
comes out if it doesn't to model we have
forecast is telling us not mostly I
wrote this presentation yesterday is
actually sunny without mostly now so I'm
very confident that it will be a good
day so take your time come out and come
to Watchers now finally just the last
things is this is the inspiring hands
for an educational activity
I think educational which is ongoing
which we call it ask ice globe
environmental science globe is a project
funded funded by the SI and the idea is
that we have an interactive way of
displaying data very similar what I've
shown you for the other scene but you
can be any data and you can manipulate
it profit on the sphere and use it so I
just finished and say come to join us
and explore this in the lobby here I am
with the mass Davos and a lot of the
visitors participated eyes were very
intrigued and try to guess where they
could fly in the world thank you very
much
[Applause]
thank you
so I wanted to start out by saying thank
you to load oh it was a real pleasure
getting the invitation to come and speak
to you all tonight
growing up one of my heroes in science
was Richard Fineman who is a fantastic
physicist but was always very passionate
about talking about how he spent time
with artists because there were these
two different parts of your brain that
needed to be exercised and so he would
sort of talk physics with these folks
and and listen to their work in art and
felt that it made him a better scientist
as a result and I've really felt that
way about talking about this project in
dealing with this project and was very
very interested to participate so one of
the things that we were asked to do this
evening was tell you a little bit of our
about our research and how it was
related to the era cien project and so I
work in the area of climate change as
John mentioned to start out and so I'm
not only a scientist but I'm also an
avid historian and so I loved the
history behind the science that we do
and so I'm starting out here with one of
my favorite quotes which is by George
Santayana those who that cannot remember
the past are condemned to repeat it and
I think that this is especially true of
climate and so what I thought I'd start
out by doing tonight is telling you a
little bit about the climate of our
planet the work that we're doing in it
and then get back to how I think we can
do it better with the type of technology
which also happens to be the art that
you're hearing about this weekend so
this is the temperature history of the
earth in the past and this goes back
almost a million years in in time and
one of the things that you can see about
it is that the earth has been warmer for
periods of time and it's been colder for
periods of time and over the course of
this time you can see that in blue here
these are ice ages when the earth has
been much colder there's also these
peaks and temperature when the earth has
been warmer we should actually be rather
thankful that currently we're living in
what we call an interstitial period and
the average temperature of our planet
right now is about 57 degrees which if
we had the average temperature in Boston
the last few weeks I think we'd all be
quite happy but over the course of the
year over the whole of the planet that
you just saw in those beautiful images
it works out that we're at about 57 to
and so one of the things that you can
ask about because we're talking about
this idea of an anthropocentric lime
ative our planet really changes quite a
bit over time and you can wonder you
know how much of this is is natural and
it turns out that over history over
almost a hundred years ago now people
had worked out that the temperature of
our planet is very variable that you
have to go through these ice ages in
these interstitial periods and it has
nothing to do with us as humans being on
the surface of the planet of course we
weren't there for most of the time and
that figure that I just showed you and a
very very smart scientist by the name of
Milankovitch figured this out and and
realized that this had to do with the
orbital mechanics of our planet how our
planet is is tilting on its axis when
it's slightly further slightly closer to
the Sun but if you zoom in on that
temperature record you start to realize
that the temperature of our planet has
changed a great deal over just the last
few generations and this is highlighted
in blue on the figure that you can see
here so instead of these big swings in
temperature that took tens of thousands
of years over just the last hundred
years or so the planet has gotten a
great deal warmer the blue actually on
here is the instrumental record it's the
period of time for which we've had
accurate thermometers to make
measurements of of climate and that
should give us some sense of how
recently we've only begun to understand
the planet that we live on it's only
just over about a hundred years that
we've been able to tell about the
climate of our planet and really
understand it by the way that longest
record of temperature that we have for
the United States was actually made just
south of us it was made in the Blue
Hills I'm starting in about the 1880s
what you realize as opposed to looking
at the last plot that I showed you where
temperature swung wildly over these tens
of thousands of years this is about the
length of human history human history
goes back of course a few thousand years
further than this recorded history but
you know this is going back into the
ages of the Roman Empire and what you'll
notice instead of these wild swings of
many degrees of temperature
instead everything on this plot is
within about a half a degree so that 57
degrees that I said for the global
average hasn't changed more than about a
half a degree in that period of time and
so one of the points that that we have
to understand when we start talking
about the Anthropocene the effect that
we've had on the planet around us is
that we've been we've grown as a
civilization in a very stable climate
perhaps the most stable climate that
this planet has seen in over a million
years and so this is no coincidence that
this has happened we've really benefited
from this and this ability to evolve in
a world that's very stable but we're
starting to move outside of that and so
I mentioned that I was a history buff
and so one of my personal interests is
understanding how it is that we've been
able to understand how we're affecting
the climate of our planet and so I this
is one of my favorite scientists this is
John Tyndall who is a Brit and he was
very interested in building different
instruments just like we do in our lab
the one that John mentioned a few
moments ago to understand how the
temperature of the planet is what it is
and so this is something that he called
a comparative spectrometer he was able
to fill this tube with different gases
and try to understand how they
interacted with solar radiation and
infrared radiation those two things that
are powering the air Essene balloons
that you're gonna be seeing more about
in the next few days and so what Tyndall
realized was that most of our atmosphere
most of what we breathe is nitrogen and
oxygen and it has no effect on the
temperature of our planet but there's a
few key elements out there carbon
dioxide being one of them which is a
so-called greenhouse gas it absorbs that
infrared energy the same thing that
powers these balloons this MRI that you
were hearing about it at night and it
allows that energy to be trapped much
like a blanket around the planet and it
raises the temperature of the planet as
a result and so now mind you from the
dates that you're seeing on there
Tyndall was doing his work in the mid to
late 1800s and he had already really
figured out the basics of the climate of
our planet at that time so if you ever
hear that climate changes is something
that we're just figuring out right now
I'll
talk about that in a few moments but
really the basics of this were all
worked out in the mid 1800s and
Tyndall's famous for writing a paper
about how if we didn't have these
wonderful greenhouse gases around our
planet we'd be caught in an icy grip and
so that tucks us to the next part of our
story who is a scientist that followed
on Tyndall's work this was spontaneous
and he was working at the end of the
1800s and the build the beginning of the
1900s and he was really intrigued by
this idea that there were these
materials in our atmosphere that could
make it warmer or colder and so what i
rainiest did was figured out how much
warmer the planet would be as a result
of having different amounts of these
greenhouse gases and so he looked at
doubling amount of co2 for example and
seeing how much warmer the planet would
get and he wasn't interested in doing
this for altruistic purposes you might
think that he was worried about
greenhouse gases and global warming the
things that we're talking about for
example at the cop21 conference the
rainiest was actually from Scandinavia
and he was interested in trying to make
the planet warmer the winters were too
long for him much like us in Boston this
year and so he was very interested in
doing things like lighting : fire to try
to make the planet warmer as a result so
not quite thinking about things the same
way we do now
so what have we done what is this
anthropocentric side and other
greenhouse gases to our atmosphere and
one of the results that this has had is
to warm the temperature of the planet so
we're now warmer than we probably have
been in in the last several thousand
years at least perhaps many tens of
thousands of years and so over that
instrumental record that I just told you
about the warmest years on record from
one to twenty year on the upper right
here I have been updated this recently
2017 just came in about a month ago at
number two on this plot and so I often
think about this because when we tell
people that the climate that children
will grow up in is different than the
climate that we grew up in the climate
that we're experiencing now is already
different than it was when we were
growing up none of the first years of my
life are actually on the top
twenty years on this plot they all fall
below that the climate of the last few
decades has been radically different
this Anthropocene has led to a radically
different world already now that we're
living in than we experienced even a
generation ago so one of the things that
that we do a great deal of is trying to
understand exactly what the climate of
our planet is and unfortunately even
thanks to the work of Tyndall and
Irenaeus back at the late 1800s Early
1900s they missed a few things in their
calculations they weren't able to get
the climate of the planet quite right
and one of the reasons is that this is
actually a beautiful image of the planet
something that I had on my wall as a
child from the Japanese space agency but
I think we already know and and Tomas
showed an earlier picture of this what
is this missing clouds the planet at any
one time should actually look like this
not the other picture and until we
understand the particulate matter in our
atmosphere
we can't understand the climate so
particles scatter some of that incoming
solar radiation just like the gases the
greenhouse gases are trapping some of
those outgoing terrestrial radiation the
infrared radiation that was spoken about
before beyond that we've even changed
the properties of the clouds in our
atmosphere there's more clouds now than
there were earlier before this
Anthropocene onset and so understanding
all of these things is something that we
critically need to do so with my last
few seconds what I want to do is try to
bring this back full circle to one of
the reasons that I'm so excited about
this project which is making these
measurements in our atmosphere is
extremely costly you can think about
having to go out and do research or get
a research aircraft and fly it at the
cost of many tens of thousands of
dollars the idea of having these
incredible small platforms things that
can be sort of crowd-sourced to do
measurements on a very local scale but
many but maybe in many places at the
same time can really add to the
knowledge that we currently have about
our planet really help us reduce that
uncertainty in how climate is going to
be changing into the future so with that
I'll say thank you I really appreciate
the chance to come out and I'm looking
forward to the panel after this
[Applause]
well thank you to load load oh and the
rest of you organizers to the
opportunity to talk here
I first met Thomas must be over five
years ago when he was
artist-in-residence here and I was
fascinated immediately by the
imagination and creativity of his
sculptures and also by his dedication to
the problems faced by the culture and by
our environment I did struggle to figure
out exactly what I was invited to talk
about since I don't work on the either
the era scene or directly on the
atmosphere but I have spent the past 10
years studying teaching and now writing
about the uses sources and systems that
involve energy so I thought I would take
some of the lessons from what I've
learned and taught and just provides
some kind of basic picture about a
couple of issues that follow from the
physics of energy the two topics I'm
going to talk about and I'm going to be
very brief and very not technical I hope
are the scale of the problem we face in
trying to convert our culture to
sustainable energy sources and secondly
a couple of lessons from the second law
of thermodynamics so first let me talk
about scale the tagline to talk about
the scale of the problem we face is the
number twenty terawatts
this is the number and it's useful to
spell it out in digits this is the
number that measures the rate at which
humanity uses primary energy twenty
times ten to the twelfth joules per
second of primary energy ninety percent
of this energy comes from burning carbon
and
associated compounds about a quarter of
it from gasoline from petroleum about a
quarter of it from coal about a quarter
of it from natural gas 10% from biomass
and waste and only about 6% from
renewables and almost all from renewable
hydropower and hydropower has already
been developed to the extent it can be
developed that leaves about 2% left for
the modern renewables of wind and solar
energy I think 20 terawatts is a hard
number to comprehend so I want to try to
translate it into some pictures and some
images that will make it more persuasive
to you this is a coal train winding its
way through the mountains of the
American West and 20 terawatts is the
energy equivalent of 2 million tons of
coal per hour fueling our modern economy
I could have shown some pictures of the
skyline of Singapore or the docks of
Long Beach to try to show you the scope
of the enterprise that this fuels but
you have to appreciate that this is an
amazing scope now we don't burn 20
million tons of coal I've reduced the
oil and the natural gas and the biomass
to the equivalent amount of coal to just
give you a picture of the effort that's
involved to make this more concrete a
typical coal train has about 120 cars
it's got about 120 tons of coal per car
that's 15,000 tons per train and we need
about a hundred and thirty fully loaded
trains of that nature to supply the
energy that our civilization thrives on
and is using in greater amount all the
time I'm not going to let go of this
easily let me try to say it another way
this is a large coal-fired power plant
in England it uses about 3 gigawatts
worth of power constantly to produce
about 1 gigawatt of electricity
in order to find an equivalent to the
carbon dioxide that we pump into the
atmosphere it would be equivalent to
three thousand two hundred of these
large coal-fired power plants operating
continuously 24 hours a day all year
long that's the rate at which we're
putting carbon dioxide into the
atmosphere I'd rather think about
renewables so let me try to convert this
number into something that relates to
renewable energy these are solar panels
they're the highest efficiency way we
have of gathering solar energy in a very
high-quality form and to supply that our
civilization with the energy that we
require it would require a million
square kilometers of silicon
photovoltaics at their current
efficiency spread out over the tropical
deserts and the tropical deserts are
chosen just because the sunniest
cloud-free areas where you could place
solar panels and get the most sunshine
the lesson I want to take from this is
the transforming society to sustainable
energy is heavy lifting this is a huge
problem it's not going to be solved
unless we marshal the resources of our
culture and convince leaders political
leaders and economists that changes in
behavior and changes in investment have
to be made over a very short time span
in order to bring a sustainable energy
revolution um the second thing I want to
talk about is the second law of
thermodynamics and it's hard to talk at
a non-technical audience is about the
second law of thermodynamics so I want
to try to say it in non technical form
the simplest non technical form is that
there is no free lunch another way of
saying it is the disorder in the
universe can only increase with time but
the implication I want to talk about
today is that some forms of energy are
more useful than others the most useful
forms of energy are those that have what
we call zero entropy or very
negligible entropy negligible disorder
and the two striking examples are
mechanical energy and electromagnetic
energy they can be translated directly
into useful work for humanity's needs
thermal energy he is a varying quality
depending upon its temperature and
sunlight is probably the highest quality
form of heat energy that's available to
us it comes from the Sun with a
temperature of six-thousand degrees
Kelvin which is about 10,000 degrees
Fahrenheit it's really hot and that
means it's very high quality in
particular the second law of
thermodynamics limits the efficiency at
which you can convert sunlight to the
most usable form of energy electricity
and that limit is 95% that's really
wonderful it means that sunlight is a
tremendous resource it can be converted
directly into useful work at a 95% level
well we use solar panels to collect
light and turn it directly into usable
electricity and there's been research on
solar panels for generations now they're
becoming cost-effective and competitive
with fossil fuels they're being mounted
on enlarged solar farms across our
country and then elsewhere in the world
and their net efficiency the rate at
which they turn solar energy into
electricity is six to seven percent so
we started with an a resource which is
95 percent potential useful energy and
what we can get out of it with the best
of our efficient solar panels on a per
square meter basis is between six and
seven percent so let me contrast that
with warmth and the example I want to
use is ocean thermal energy now people
have known for years that the surface of
tropical oceans is warm
to the abyssal depths in fact the
surface of tropical oceans average is
about 27 degrees centigrade and the
depths are just a few degrees above
freezing five degrees centigrade there's
a picture here showing a slice through
some tropical ocean where you can see
the very hot water on the top and the
depth the depth with the purple cut and
magenta color indicates very cold water
and you can build an engine just like
you can build an engine that works on
coal you can build an engine that takes
that heat from the surface waters runs
an engine and dumps the extra entropy
that must be created the extra disorder
into the cold water at the depths the
same laws of thermodynamics that allow
solar energy to be at most theoretically
95% efficient allow ocean thermal energy
to be seven percent efficient that's the
best you could do if you satisfied all
the conditions of efficiency that are
available so what's the situation well
there are devices that have been
proposed and a couple have been set up
experimentally that this is a kind of
cross-section through such a device it
takes warm water at the surface runs an
engine dumps cold water at depth and
nobody's achieved anything that can be
measured as an efficiency so far so if
95 ramps down to seven by the time we're
finished with our crude ways of getting
power we're seven percent going to take
us so I want to start I want to end on
an optimistic note this is my last slide
I want to just emphasize the promise of
solar energy um this is a resource that
streams to earth at about 20,000 times
the rate at which human beings use
energy it's high-quality it can be
harvested efficiently we don't know how
to do that yet we don't know how to
store it effectively and we don't know
how to transmit it as effectively as we
should but the resource is immense and
the conversion to electrical energy at
high efficiency is possible and at
moderate efficiency is really within
grasp and it offers the promise for
renewable
a future thank you so um I'd like to
invite the panel up to for discussion so
what we're gonna do we have half an hour
right okay so what we're gonna do is I'm
we we would love your questions your
comments your thoughts were the a room
like this is kind of funny because we're
here in the front you're back there
really should be in the round we should
be all sitting around because we're in
one room we should all have a discussion
actually I'm gonna start it off though
as you're thinking about your questions
and your comments and when you do have a
question please come up to the mics tell
us your name and and ask your question
so I'm gonna start off with Tomas
appropriately so Bob's thoughts about a
transition to a low-carbon world and the
numbers behind that are illuminating and
the eye
I always think involves the the keeper
of the laws of nature right I wish and
and I'd actually really like to hear
more Tomas about the bridge to a
fossil-free future that you use that
tagline and actually maybe walking and
the work that you showed was really
compelling because there's a pathway
that involves citizen science and
community engagement which is something
completely different than necessarily
the technological on the science pathway
could you talk a little bit more and
like even if you want to say a few words
as well so know an interesting model so
Bob you could maybe general ad is kind
of thermodynamically imagination that we
are trying to pursue in kind of these
elemental way of you know because there
is always this coupling of metabolic
regimes of how we have been living on
planet Earth and how in different times
humans have kind of evolved in
relationship how will their grasping the
resource is now the first kind of
metabolic regime we were hunters and
gatherers nomads tribes around the world
we will always follow the season and
follow the Sun right then we invented
agriculture agriculture which became
sedentary the second battle over we
domesticate the Sun domesticate the
animals and somehow we managed to became
sedentary in a certain area in the third
metabolic regime we kind of learn how to
extract more from the Sun and you know
we learn how to burn charcoal which
somehow Iraq you know how many millions
of years have of some influence it
needed to then be able to burn does it
mean we start to have all these
extractive economies which somehow also
you know expanded civilization to became
Afghan and you know this kind of Graham
you know I think so how much population
now is living on the cities does it mean
for metabolic regime that somehow we're
proposing is like in what happened when
you know these extractive economies and
with all these resources and also the
way of offer because every metabolic
regime somehow also I have allow
different modes of aggregation of people
you know when we were nomads the tribes
cannot grow to a certain extent and the
other one keep growing crib run doesn't
mean the relationship we always have
established of how we have related our
society with the Sun so these metabolic
regime may also get products of you know
transportation mobility and so forth is
Amin now it's a rather speculation
things but thinking you know because
what it does is it cross this camp idea
of Cabiria lament I know you the Sun is
heated up you don't need a solar panel a
battery or converted to electricity
directly it get to maybe something I'd
like to speculate from after all more
some people maybe we became homos
flotantes and we became number the
beginning of the atmosphere and you
might think ho we were fish is floating
the water why we moved to the land and
why we might be the benefit to move into
the air
there but you know really type 2 maybe
anyone anyone else want to think well
maybe I just would add one thing that I
I think that a transformation of
society's way of thinking about its
culture and energy is a really important
part of dealing with the energy transfer
the transformation to renewable energy
we demand that we can turn on our
washing machine at any time of day we
expect to be able to take a car wherever
we want to go and you know the the
variability of their energy sources that
you have to deal with for example with
solar energy and versus infrared energy
if human beings adapted to the cadences
at which energy is available it would
make a big impact on what we have to do
in order to reach a sustainable future
so please like please come up to the
mics I actually wanted on follow-up with
lucky I'm gonna ask you to say some
words because I'm very curious is I'm
very curious about a particular thing so
the the outcomes that you are after when
engaging the community especially a
community that is under pressure from
environmental conditions right okay what
what what do you what what happens what
what are the actions that the community
takes all right to begin with
I'm gonna be honest sometimes I feel a
little pessimistic about weather and
climate change I have a few friends in
Harvard who are architects and are
actually here and yesterday we were
talking about what we called the brace
for impact
scenario you know and I was asking them
when is that coming and we realized that
we are already leaving the brace for
impact
scenario because of the you know amount
of times we are seeing all these extreme
weather events so in terms of community
I think
this is gonna change us a lot you know
we are gonna have to find new ways to
relate to each other new ways to help
each other new ways to learn from each
other and this is why I am basashi this
future of technological developments
that might seem basic but might actually
be very helpful like this idea of
creating a solar aerial mesh network and
I imagined places where they're having
floods in the past years and how do you
deploy relief efforts team to a place
that has suffered a natural disaster and
this is where I think of this you know
network that runs on clean solar energy
but just to sum it up I very much agree
with Bob of the sheer size of the
problem and actually each of us has a
role in this you know maybe we can start
thinking how to live more
energy-efficient life so thanks thank
you questions
[Music]
so this may be a challenge for my dear
friend Tomas but I would be interested
in the others the human architectural
fascination with life in a capsule so
the sky city the Cloud City the Bucky
fuller spaceship City these are in fact
incredibly energy intensive right they
are the sort of emotional manifestation
of freedom that is the result of
intensively you know energy intensive
manufacturing processes
you know delivery systems
infrastructures of power that are
somehow you know brought up there as
batteries or whatever so in a way it's a
challenge to the nomadic fantasy and how
this is coupled with the very elaborated
technologies that would make such a
cloud city possible is that ok it's a
tough question it's like tough love life
no I think you know you know it's so
simple as you can start to reuse plastic
bag instead of downgrading material you
upscale relationship of the relation you
have with plastic bags and very happy
that now you know plastic bags through
Missouri solar into community suddenly
can give another lifespan or the
lifetime correspond with their ability
of themselves to be within the
environment we have created
ok now let's let's put it away this o1x
is there this mean now first you know
it's like I will always like you know
the idea of you know in bruno latour we
are condemned to live in a sub Lana
right sublunar that we somehow you know
the Bible is somehow planet earth today
and we have kind of an environmental
justice responsibility also the amount
of people who are on board on these
special earth and Bruno doesn't like in
the analogy but somehow you know I think
so when you understand also the
constraint
where we are living you are living in a
bubble to certain extent right and there
are some resources that somehow maybe
you can start to relate differently
isn't there is this kind of logic on
that you mean the other is also like
when you think in the way that I
proposed or so I think so is like a and
I think so what we ever seen that is
also how to fly with a feet on the
ground does it mean there is a huge
responsibility that's I think so when
you scale it too fast too quickly then
you end up in a modernist dream
but while the way of how we are doing
the things today here we working with
Laura with a measurement the quality of
the air well let's give it a little bit
more time you know fuel it also sell
like there is no lack of energy there is
no energy crisis there is a crisis of
imagination and how it can couple and
recover our self with environment is I
mean I think so the relationship of
trying to say is like oh how complex is
you know when I was at NASA in 2009
people have to put people in the moon
and I said for 300 euro you collect a
couple of plastic bag and you can lift
up yourself from the ground they cannot
believe it does it mean there is somehow
is such an addiction of people of
thinking the infrastructure and you need
to do such a thing
that is unbelievable for them to get out
of this and is it mean you know anytime
that you demonstrate these people say
hard you know there's some kind of magic
now I challenge yourself and you know
let's put it away you know and you know
that this it's quite cheap we are really
working now coz on something which is a
300 meter sphere diameter which could be
also like a which can be able to lift up
a couple of hundred people up into the
earth rigid sphere and it's incredible
chief if I tell you in the
infrastructure is something even an
artist can understand and reteach to
whole community of scientists or
reengage from trained understanding how
we can sense the Sun differently or how
you know I mean just so only I mean with
Laura we know but you know have been
with director of NASA and people at is I
said what is the average of the jet
stream they don't know it you know how
long it will take you to make around the
world actually you know the only what
you know is like okay in a current plane
you got to your destination half an hour
early if the wind was blowing but now if
you are drifting no if you are in a kind
of a drift a kind of drift
situation
you know it's like it take quite an
effort and I think so he's not right I
think so too all the time you know
condemn some idea of of thinking that
infrastructure is so gigantic well
actually very simpler it's simple as a
plastic bag in the hands of somebody
else
so my question is regarding the solar
balloons that you guys talked about so
assuming that you will be able to launch
these balloons at the location that you
like to what is the vision what is the
plan if you collect all these data all
across the planet then where does that
data go and what you are what are you
expecting to get out of it what is de
you know plan for it if panel could
speak to it a little bit the second
question is for the efficiency of the
solar power so I want to find out what
is the bottleneck not to have higher
efficiency and so what what is the
efficiency that we are aiming for to
replace that hundred thirty coal trains
per hours so can you give a sense what
we are looking at it there the data well
as I mentioned before there different
type of data you can collect if you go
higher up in the stratosphere normally
would be monitoring their ozone you know
the zone layer is very important for
life on Earth and if you have depletion
of ozone you know you can get the all
the relevant light which comes to us and
be very damaging so this is why it's a
monitoring to make sure that we we had
an example of an ozone hole not long ago
with just recovering out of that so it's
the kind of monitoring to make sure but
another other gases like Danny's being
intentional about like co2 methane which
are very important for the as a
greenhouse so it increase of those
glasses makes the temperature alerts
increases enormously and so we want to
monitor to make sure that those are not
increasing too much of what is the trend
that we notice so those are the upper
level a low level with a tender balloon
you can actually monitor the air quality
so all these particle I was talking
about and chemical at a very
damaging to your health so they're the
result mainly a combustion they can
produce acid rain and they are also
particle itself or dimension that they
can be very very bad for your health so
the quality of the air locally is very
important for when you live and it is
monitor you know you got you know in the
summertime you have a lot of sometimes
pollutant trapped in the lower
troposphere and it can be very I come
from a region of Milan where you have a
very poor air quality we have heard
about machine and all this big city so
they can be very efficient in in
measuring the what is the chemistry of
those of those lower tropospheric layer
what's going on there and how we can
control the pollution so there are
different type of monitoring the you
didn't do to follow up on what loto just
said another thing that that we've
really struggled with the scientists
over the last couple decades is
shrinking budgets and there's really
only a handful of research aircraft that
we can do these high quality
measurements with especially talking
about things like the ozone layer we're
still relying on Cold War era aircraft
er 2's the old u-2 spy planes that have
been retasked things like that they cost
many tens of thousands of dollars per
hour
they're absolutely necessary to validate
new satellites that go up to understand
the quality of the ozone to make sure
that the ozone hole is indeed still
closing something that we are just
getting out of and so the idea that we
might have these platforms that could
allow this us to do this at much lower
cost in many more locations is is really
intriguing and and the surface
measurements as well
we're notoriously bad about making most
of our measurements in the northern
hemisphere where most of the developed
countries are and notoriously bad about
making too few measurements in the
southern hemisphere and this idea of
low-cost platforms that we could look at
these types of problems understand air
quality for example in some of the large
cities in the southern hemisphere is
something that we critically need to do
as scientists
jerking an example he's talking about
community in outside Buenos Aires which
I've very badly affected by pollution
you can see them we had an example like
that in Venice when it's a beautiful
city when I was growing up you will
approach Venice in your level huge came
out a chemical plant there and there was
terrible quality so they probably are in
the same situation but you can improve
that by with rules and regulation and
your health is badly affected by the
pollution well you do it you do it you
do it by yourself
you could look at people collecting data
we collected we will do the experiment
on Saturday we can collect it you can
have community is your kin is trying to
make a community responsible for trying
to collect some more information and
then the data itself would be if you can
show that it's so bad you can for some
political action yeah there is a group
we work which called well beside being
with powerless are a part of Red Cross
also which they kind of engaged also
within the project there's a group which
is called public lab they do a lot of
environmental justice and it's been in
the hands of them they provide a lot of
downgrading or kind of low scale
monitoring devices which we hope so you
know we're working together with high
scientists with low communities also
coming up together wait and there
they're building huge cases also two big
multinational also you know in the case
of shale which is coming up in the
vision flammable a work Hakeem is
talking you can build up huge cases on
trying to measure and giving the hands
of them the way you have the monitor
environment I think I owe you an answer
to the second part of your question I'm
really there are two things to say the
first is that seven percent is a final
efficiency for solar energy is not as
bad as it may sound it's more that it's
a bad starting place for ocean thermal
energy but millions I was writing an
article about this and I said a million
square kilometres is half the
surface area of Libya and the person I
was writing it for said people don't
know how big lip he is so maybe you
should convert it to Texas plus Oklahoma
so then it becomes as problem of storage
and transmission people are very
refractory about having transmission
lines strung across their landscape but
electric high voltage DC electric
transmission is very efficient and could
carry electricity from faraway places to
where it's needed the second is you
where how did 95% get down to 7% some
people in the audience may be perplexed
because you can read that the efficiency
of PV modules now is about 20% but when
you lay them out on the landscape they
have to be tilted at an angle and they
block each other there have to be
pathways between them so that people can
walk and clean them up when they get
dirty there's piping and support
structures there are inverters that
change it from DC to AC and that knocks
it down by a factor about two and a half
from 20% to seven and a half percent in
principle silicon can get to about 30%
in efficiency consistent with the laws
of thermodynamics okay Mary responding
to the visionary nature of the project
and some of that earlier works such as
City skies I'm curious if the panel
could comment on whether or not they
think that it's possible to even imagine
physically a floating city I've been
very inspired by an interested in
buckminster fuller's cloud9 project just
maybe some which is a related project a
city with a mild wide diameter that
floats in the sky he makes a very
persuasive argument to a layperson but
I'm curious to know if the panel has any
thoughts about whether or not this could
be possible I think so I mean the
problem is like you know sometimes you
what with something which is very you
know it's like a what I think so is it
if you
take the challenge yourself and you'd
really try to build it and to build a
very infrastructure which is different
than the infrastructure that usually
things are built and with such a
responsibility distributed agency of how
we try to the project grow bit by bit
sometime I'm very anxious I mean it
would be very different color they have
a different understanding of what it
might be this cloud cities and which
type of political challenge we might be
facing with them now something very
simple when we float and we make a
worldwide record to lift up a person in
the air with a certified vehicle in the
white sand and when we were trying to
repeat the same in a surface which is
not white we were not lifting it in one
person does it mean your power of being
how much people you can carry up into
the air
it's really depend about the surface
they'll be the reflectivity of the earth
and I mean this could be the clouds or
could be the surface of the air you can
also see and think about a sea when it's
very calm and you don't have some ripple
in the water this mean this alone is
kind of an amazing thermometer is it is
an amazing sensor will go up and down
and really we've something which are
because you know there is human still we
are so stable there I was like oh you
cannot look at the cosmos you're not
looking at you you know out of the scale
is the problems at all on earth but
there are few people who really
understand this choreography this
relationship between the Earth and the
Sun is idea to when Laura was doing all
this drawing going up then going down
and being able to understand these
boundary layers when we leave and there
people sometimes are very or escapade no
you get that or you are getting here you
cannot be in between and it's been you
know it's like every time that you try
to and this means is tomorrow is like we
became so much weather dependent is it
mean it's tomorrow or maybe not tomorrow
maybe not and they after tomorrow no
remember all that psychology of people
is like a turnkey solution is a cut-down
well here is the curtain is much more
gentle do you see the Sun coming from
the horizon you kind of float gravity
seem to reverse itself space is top to
be a you know the Khurram line is 300
kilometers high with of
start to fall when we form upward we
reverse our self this mean easy you know
steam is emotion you move with a wing
you became the wind there are a lot of I
mean if you take it serious start to do
I think so in the moment that a cloud
city might be up there I think so we
might help solve already down here on
planet Earth maybe we have been learned
how to live on that bubble called birth
today and maybe we may get ready to get
another step towards somewhere else
right the solar sails and whatever it
might be there but it is I don't know
another thing for example you know come
front of an institute it kind of MIT
from Jeremy say what might be kind of a
monument you know that we have been
Eiffel Towers the London I think about a
city again because they would usually we
do is educational path when it's a high
wind voltage you have a lot of problem
to storage in batteries and the
distribution also and it mean the best
things you can do when you have a lot of
wind you get an SMS in your telephone
tell you now wash your closes because
it's cheaper the high rate of you know
that's the moment you have to consume
energy because there is a lot of wind
and I mean what are thinking like it
okay think about it
meaning Cloud City something when is
very windy usually will be down this
mean is the time to wash your clothes it
is it means the Eiffel Tower you can fly
up and down and it's a symbol for the
city of reconnect yourself with
something that sometime you know you can
just pick up the clothes and put it on
the Sun too bright
these come very Turtles this addiction
we have to certainly relation so I
actually want to dive into this question
myself so I run a group called the urban
metabolism group and what we do is
account for the resources that we all
consume on an annual basis so our
floating cities cloud cities possible
well so all of you on average in this
part of the world consume between 25 and
30 tons per capita per year so if we can
figure out a way to put 20 to 30 tons
per capita each one of us up in the sky
then it's possible yes the other answer
I want to give the other the second part
through this answer is there is a city
of eight million people in in the sky
every day in fact that's the average
number of people who fly every day
and they're connected you know on their
iPads and everything so there-there is a
city in the sky today it's it's fossil
fuel driven it's not that vision but
it's absolutely there so that's another
you know that's really very much our
reality so other questions please go to
the mic if you can you know see the
floating back sample you know eighty
years ago you know just thinking about
flying just one person flying by itself
right now you can have a 380 floating
and you know it's right it's almost zero
you see the floating there just have it
means an engine and when you really make
your imagination go it's feasible to you
start floating there on the eerily
balloons you know so it doesn't visible
now my question here is you know it's
and great minds here trying to do the
right thing but then you have the other
side the economy side they say you know
what we are the owners of the coil
companies we are honored to know the oil
companies we really don't want to fund
you because we we found you we're gonna
be useless hi woody we have politics
eyes you know I say you know why we how
we convince the people that has a fun in
to actually invest in the right thing to
do but so you know I don't want to find
you because I want to keep sustaining
myself I don't care about what's
happening with the rest of that who
would like to tackle that come on come
come tomorrow and day after tomorrow
it's interesting these panels you know
it strikes me that this could be a
day-long symposium because there are
some major themes that are just gonna
get not really touched on but this is
obviously one of them I guess I could
just say a word on it which is that you
know maybe taking it one step further
which is that I it's very hard for us to
say we live here in a developed country
that developed itself on a carbon
economy right I mean so we have the
quality of life that we have because of
fossil fuels here everything around us
was built on that and so you know one of
the problems is is moving forward not
just keeping things the same but
acknowledging that there's developing
countries and and this is like saying to
them you
can't develop in the same way that we
did but not at the same time offering
them a replacement technology it so I
guess I'm just taking your question
maybe one step further but you know I
firmly believe that that one of the
things that we are gonna have to do as a
society is make the hard choices coming
up and I think it was pointed out that
we've already maybe gotten to this point
where we see the onset of severe storms
you know higher temperatures heat deaths
things like that that at some point
we're not going to be able to ignore it
anymore and because a few corporations
wish to continue to make a profit is not
gonna balance out with the increasing
penalties that we're all paying as a
civilization as a society for those
things and it's going to be a slow
process I I don't think that you know
some people sort of think about turning
fossil fuels off tomorrow that's not
going to happen it's going to be a
gradual decline some of those those
those power plants you were showing
we're being put online now and they have
lifetimes of decades those aren't going
to be shut off the ones that are coming
online today are going to be around as
long as I'm gonna be around but what we
can hope is that there's going to be
more of the renewables maybe some of the
other alternative energy technologies
coming into play and that we slowly ramp
those things down but I do have to bring
us back to this idea that we do have to
think about developing countries at the
same time handing technology off to them
and trying to see them develop not in
our footsteps not with the carbon
footprint that we've had but with the
new footprint hopefully much more
renewable hopefully much more of these
alternative energies we have well I
wanted to say a couple of things one is
that it's I think it's a delusion to
think that the laws of physics are going
to be surmounted in the next
yura that in a hundred years ago people
didn't know how to fly and now they know
how to fly that's true but the laws of
buoyancy have been understood for a long
time as have the laws of absorption and
emission of radiation and there's no
sign that there's going to be a change
in those laws over the lifetime that
we're concerned with
the other thing I wanted to mention is
and III really want to say if a word in
favor of the kind of art that Tomas is
involved in I think art has a political
impact and can be used to agitate and
change people's minds about things and
that the when you talk about influencing
companies you if you create a movement
if you create political agitation if you
elect people who will pass carbon tax to
place a cost on the externalities of
filling up the atmosphere with a toxic
gas I think you'll have the possibility
of making real changes yep the other
which I want to add we have to be very
careful and maybe Carolyn can help in
Leela on the idea of the we we we know
there are many people they kind of hate
the term Anthropocene because actually
who produced this mess where we're
living is a small percentage of
population who live on planet Earth and
then many people we call it a capital
scene right is I mean we have to be very
careful because now suddenly it's like
we we we well actually there are many
people who knows how to leave every late
on planet Earth and actually the cause
of the problems and then later than
putting in danger the people who are
suffering the consequences or
hyper-consumption are kind of is really
in balance and then somehow we always
keep calling like we human where we put
everybody in the back even is it quite
of a complicated issue over that there
so we're at the end of the panel session
thank you so much for coming but please
join me in thanking the panel
and especially Tomas and Joaquin and the
whole team please join us in lobby 10
for the arrow scene demonstration of the
flow predictor and weather permitting
tomorrow and Saturday please join us in
Killian Court for floating the arrow
scene thank you